I think we can agree that democracy is a
wonderful system for people who are
basically insane Dave berry is the
author of approximately 11 D billion
books and the recipient of exactly one
Pulitzer Prize for four decades he wrote
a weekly column syndicated from his home
base of the Miami Herald and he is the
author of the annual despairing
hilarious Year in Review
Barry's books form the basis for a
short-lived show about his life Dave's
world and his novel big trouble was made
into a film of the same name
that's bullet go through your head it's
the story of a bunch of miscreants who
wind up inadvertently stealing a nuclear
suitcase and hijacking a plane due to
their own incompetence the film was set
to be released in auspiciously on
September 12 2001 what is this garbage
disposal i sat down with Barry to talk
about his new book lessons from Lucy
America's strategic helium reserve first
of all we need elio country need can't
have a country without helium yeah
probably so I would go to war for the
helium yeah the jokes he can't tell
anymore and his perennial vaguely
libertarian campaign for the presidency
I am also running for president of the
United States
[Music]
we last spoke you last spoke with reason
in 1994 and at the time figures about
time you know we didn't want to
overexpose five years of glad we thought
it was about time to bring you back to
our viewers at the time you were running
for president are you still running for
president well yeah I mean in the sense
that and and I used to view it as sort
of a joke but it's getting harder NAR
yeah well I think that you will be
officially the 25th entrant into the
2020 field I think if you are running I
think right now we took a poll in Iowa
I'd be ahead of Bill DeBlasio by wait a
bit like quite a bit not a little a lot
yeah and and that's only because he's
one of the he's the most obscure one
whose name I can actually think of there
are people far more obscure than Bill
DeBlasio and I'd be ahead of them too I
think there might be a special hatred
for Bill DeBlasio in Iowa so I think
that was a good edge there should be I
was just in New York and and I I can I
can I didn't sense let me put it this
way this sense I would have mentioned it
occasionally people he's running for and
the the the feeling among New Yorkers
this is think you would think his base
is not real positive not a groundswell
no but the day of Barry campaign on the
other hand who's a juggernaut taking off
what is your platform well the number
one thing that really got me started yes
sir a reason related thing was low-flow
toilets I was against them I was one of
the first people against them and um I'm
still against them I think we still have
them yes but I I like to point out that
we we had really great toilets in this
country when I grew up with you probably
did two great toilets make America's
bathrooms great again we could suck down
a mature sheep with our toilets and now
now you know look what we're dealing
with so there's a point kind of a
bedrock principle right that's my like
the equivalent of Trump's wall - that is
like just toilets like we're taking away
from us by regulators yeah is so it's a
kind of a deregulation thing and then of
course I'm always up for accepting Kim
you know campaign contributions that's a
kind of a fundamental part of my
campaign is is people giving money to it
how's that going not so well at the
moment but I'm glad to have this
opportunity to make yeah just do a
little ice cream
fund-raising I take venmo I I think I'll
have to ask my daughter how it works but
I would take it if if it were available
good and I mean in general you have a
long glorious history of using the
federal government as a punchline well
I've said this for many years if you
view the federal government as a form of
entertainment it's a lot easier to just
cope with it mentally so I vote when I
write the you know quarterly check for
my income taxes I think that I'm getting
a lot of a lot of value for that lately
I feel the federal government is just
strictly as an entertainment
entertainment medium it's pretty good
it's pretty good what do you say to
people that are like you know Dave it's
a it's all very well and good but like
things are really serious now well I
will give a semi serious answer to that
I I mean I'll give I'll give them that
there are issues that they should be
upset about and issues we're all upset
about but I believe I had a lot of
friends who when when Trump was elected
president
honestly fought and I don't know why
they thought this but they thought they
were gonna be in trouble with the police
for I don't know why and I would say to
them if you know like the Coral Gables
please find a time to come around to
your house arrest you or something let
me know okay I'll do anything I can just
but there was kind of that level of
concern so it's you know that's insane
and I think those people have served
figured that out at some point that it's
it's um you know whatever's happening
it's happening in a much more macro
level than that but even there
you know I always Liz will write my
lecture that where I turn into old
person for my kids like I grew up in the
60s when in this very city that we're in
right now Washington DC there were
troops in the streets fires raging
snipers on building the president was
assassinated a couple years before then
his brother was assassinated in
Martinique
there's last say there was less not to
mention the war in Vietnam and the civil
rights movement where it was pretty
clear that you know terrible things were
happening in the South you know
oh I don't I can't imagine you would
look at all that and say that right now
today things are worse I just
does that maybe a stupid old person I to
take comfort in the fact that the entire
late 60s appeared to be on fire but I
also didn't live through it so maybe
that's why you missed it I missed all
the bad times yeah apparently you know
just it is there's so much drama in
people's minds now you know Twitter
fuelled drama about how everything is
just horrible and I'm just too old as
[ __ ] it I can only take like 100% yeah
yeah I I'm just not gonna get that upset
about um you know pretending you know
there has to be some actual issue that
to make me more upset are you a Twitter
er do you spend a lot of time I I have a
Twitter account and I do tweet from time
to time like once a week maybe and but
I'm mostly view Twitter as a good way to
get on the morning and look at it while
I'm going to the bathroom which is the
time to look at it about the right
amount time and not to get too you know
detailed I mean we've already we've
already like been twice to the bathroom
and I know maybe like just a yeah one
more word on this Mike that's my I was
gonna say bread and butter but that
sounds ready
yeah that's not where was it oh yeah so
I and I look through Twitter anything
everybody's got the same people that are
always upset about things are still
upset about those things I same people
who are getting them you're wrong about
that here's my clever retort
oh yeah well here's my even clever
they're still all doing that you know I
don't know where they find the time or
the energy to be honest but it kind of
reassures me that whatever our
meaningless my life is currently it is
not that meaningless that that's what
I'm doing all day that's the good part
of Twitter in the past you've described
yourself as a soft libertarian as
cynical libertarian do you have a
preferred modifier I'm always afraid to
even bring up libertarian cuz there's so
many really like on your case
libertarians ready to determine it
you're the wrong kind you probably are
I'll just come out and say you're the
wrong kind of like many many tests of
purity but I I'm here's the kind of I'm
the kind of libertarian who's like when
there's a group of people at a party I'm
the only one who is the libertarian so
you know I don't have to worry about
which which stratum of Liberty
I'm on you can robberies I'm
representing all the and and I'm and my
my it's always at the basic level of
what about the roads we wanted to have
any roads you know that that's kind of
level of libertarian that III never get
really beyond the what are the roads
won't people have sex with goats if we
don't have a lot so you know I'm
fighting the easy fights I'm not
fighting other libertarians about you
know like really fine fine-tuned issues
of libertarianism but won't people have
sex well they sure will I in Miami they
heck heck yes that's where I live so you
mean I know I will as soon as it's legal
yeah I'm flying you back yeah no same
definitely you sometimes say you're not
a satirist you don't do satire you're a
humorist what does that distinction mean
to you well I get yeah to me okay
my joke definition satire humor that is
not funny that's to say you read it and
you know the person is not serious and
it's trying to make you laugh but it
never rises to the level of being
actually funny and when I was an English
major in college I read a lot of satire
and it was usually like Jonathan Swift
you know something like that and you get
well that was a joke one joke took them
like you know 8,000 words and I get why
you know if you had a lot of time on
your hand and nothing else to do that
would be one of the more funny things
you would you read probably in life but
nowadays I don't know there's a lot of
other humor out there so to me it's just
like jokes that just make you laugh
that's humor like Anthony Jeselnik is
funny though this you know within a
minute of watching him you'll laugh like
probably against your will but you'll
think you're a horrible person for
gaming but you will laugh what jokes
used to be funny to you that aren't
funny now no are you another way of
asking that was good that I'm allowed to
say I think so that was actually say
like alright have you gotten woke the
kid like is there anything where you're
like you know actually very not so much
not because I didn't really ever trade
particularly in any kind of ethnic humor
or I guess sexist humor I mean I've made
a
living out of talking about the
differences between men and women I have
to say I personally like I read all your
books growing up a hundred percent of
what I believed about the differences
between the genders was based on Dave
Barry's guide to guys so thank you for
that it served me well and I just I
don't know if somebody would look at it
now and say well I saw an acceptable but
I I don't really think there's anything
I would change I still think that most
of us living in the the world sense or
not done so that we know there are
certain fundamental differences between
am I even allowed to say the genders
between the sexes I think if you say all
the genders all the yeah and you know
and they're funny the way that the sexes
interact and you know so I guess maybe
somebody would say that's not woke but
I'm not really up for changing I would
say the one okay remember there used to
be polish jokes yes this is like the 60s
70s and there were millions of them and
there were sometimes very funny but I
don't think anymore I would tell a
Polish joke you know unless it was is
that because like no one identifies as
holy that's yeah I wouldn't get a laugh
that's reason no I I would just I would
think maybe somebody could rightfully
find that offensive so it was like it
was a person I knew who was polish and
he and I were good for my best friends
are our polish and then that we we would
just laugh and laugh but then I would
get him to tell a joke about my
ethnicity which nobody knows so I'm safe
you in your new book lessons from Lucy
which is about your old happy dog you do
say I believe that Lucy is Jewish yeah
so well yes I do say Lucy that's one
thing um I'm married to a Jewish woman
my daughter's be raised Jewish
identifies as Jewish but my and my son
married a Jewish woman I've been the guy
who held the baby at a bris you know so
I'm and I go to Temple even though I'm
personally an atheist and grace raised
Episcopalian I'm not sure where I'm
going with this
oh yeah Jews they're really good about
not taking themselves too seriously they
you you can Jews will still tell Jewish
jokes and they're really
always funny there inevitably funny and
so I don't know if I'm allowed to went
because I'm married to a Jewish woman
tell Jewish jokes I do anyway but you
had a potential run-in with politically
incorrect humor with the movie made out
of your book big trouble you tell us the
story of big trouble yeah trouble that
it got into oh man well so the plot
involves a bomb aboard a nuclear weapon
on a plane and but it was otherwise
comedy at least I thought it was funny
and it was so sick I'm out September 12
2001 the day after 9/11 and so that was
the first phone call I got second phone
call you got the morning of 9/11 was the
movie people saying the movies not going
to come out and so that it sort of
dribbled out months later and didn't
really but I don't know if it did well
or not but it that so the boys 9/11
really screwed me over nicely not to in
any way compare my getting screwed with
emails but one other thing about that
that movie in it the the Russians are
gangsters and I went to Russia a few
years ago for the United States State
Department as part of a program where
they with they send they attempt to
ignite international incident they sent
authors already you're supposed to
increase understanding well and we see
how well that's working and and so I
went there and they said well while
you're there you we were gonna we
usually have this thing where we have
movie night at the st. Petersburg
Embassy not Embassy but whatever it's
called they and they have a movie night
where they bring in all the Russians who
want to come and they show an American
movie is that why don't we show your
movie now the previous a couple weeks
I've been traveling around doing talks
for various groups all around Russia and
and one of the things oh it is ask them
is you know what do you think our
misconceptions are about Russians and I
always said two things you think we're
all drunk and you think we're all
gangsters so ok then I comes time for me
to present this movie big trouble to a
group of Russians and I thought I'd
better quickly
review the plot and the first stance is
that it has Russians in it and the
second area is they're gangsters so I
had to get up in front of this whole
room full of Russians and say you my
movie does have Russians in it and they
are gangsters and there's like I see
this these groans but I said they're
they're much smarter than the American
gangsters in so there's that sort of
pro-russian gangster movie you had I
think if anything is your catchphrase
it's you know I'm not making this up we
now live in the era of fake news did we
always live in the era of fake news I
mean the need to reassure people as far
ago as you know your early columns he
just maybe distrust of the media is not
a new phenomenon well when I started
saying I'm not making subs because the
things I were talking about were so
ridiculous and I lie a lot in my column
becomes mostly lies so when those rare
occasions when I was gonna say something
that really did happen I would say I'm
not making this up as an indication that
it's you know even though it's
ridiculous and it's in my column it's
true so it wasn't really talking about
the you know distortions and biases on
the part of news media people although
they've always existed I mean I've spent
my life in the newspaper business
obviously a lot of us are biased and and
we we like to say we're not but that's
not what I was talking about Florida man
let's talk briefly about Florida man you
did not invent the concept of Florida
man you only occasionally actually are
Florida man in the deepest spiritual
sense what do you make of the rise of
the meme of Florida man and are you
responsible no I'm not responding that a
Florida is responsible for you can trace
when that happened to the 2000
presidential election when Florida was
unable to determine who had voted for
for like several weeks and really is
still sure who it voted for and I think
we should just give our electoral votes
to like Montana or someplace that can
count some are more responsible yeah or
just
just not us anymore because they lorry
up mocked and then there are these
incidents that happen in Florida and
enough of them happened people start
noticing that they're having it's not
like they're not happening anywhere else
but they are happening a probably
disproportional nimble disproportionate
number happening in Florida because
there's a lot of people in Florida and
because a lot people didn't start there
I mean that's my big defense of Florida
is that most of these people you know
like if you just are seized by a need to
get naked and pleasure yourself in a
stuffed animal in a Walmart you're not
gonna probably do that in Zanesville
Ohio you're gonna go you're gonna go to
Miami you're gonna go to Tampa you're
gonna go down there where it's warm and
a welcoming environment for that kind of
behavior so we have a we're like I said
the Ellis Island for weird stupid people
they come to us to do their weird stupid
things and you know that's sort of
become our and I think it's a good thing
I hate really first of all I live there
so it's like material just shows up on
washes up on my doorstep if you're human
writer there's no better place to live
than Florida but also it's sort of like
it protects the rest of the nation all
right they can all look down on us if
they want to get naked in a Walmart they
know where they can go and it's it's
it's entertainment it's like a massive
forum every morning DJ in the country is
every morning's reading Florida man
stories
so we're it's good what's wrong what's
bad about it
has it been good for your original home
paper I mean the Miami on the Florida
man beat yeah it is people still want to
work at the Miami Herald just because so
many weird things happen in the Miami
area so the young people who would
otherwise be wise enough to never pick
journalism as a career are drawn to it
come in so we have low paid workers is
that your advice to young people
considering becoming journalists like
don't do it but if you must Florida yeah
you mean they come to at least go
someplace interesting sorry for the
short time before you get bought out or
fired cool let's talk about your new
book lessons from Lucy it's about your
dog I want to just confess right now I
am NOT a dog
how can you not be a dog person well
okay you don't have to own a dog be you
I don't really like them how can you not
like dog I find it confusing that people
want like gross animals and have you
ever had a dog if you're underdog I when
I was a kid we briefly had a dog we
didn't really bond and what happened
tell me that's just a total oh oh are we
gonna have it therapy session about my
relations I uh it was just a little show
me where the dog touched you it's a dog
she hung around uneventful E and then
done do you like okay here's the real
quick do you like any other animal do
you like cats no okay well then we can't
it's not that I barely like people let's
that's a whole different thing
who likes people to be on you like your
dog you I love dogs dog Lucy I do
possibly the only dogs I feel finally
about were earnest and zippy they were
great to the main dog and the backup dog
auxiliary dog yes of some of your
earlier books but the book isn't really
about dogs it's really about the fact
that you are super old yeah yes that is
what it's about
what does Lucy teach you about being
super old well do you take objecting to
super I could just go go no I'll go I'll
cop to super I mean I'm about to turn 72
it's like the next major birthday I face
is 80 so how can you not call me old and
I was just at my 50th college reunion
and if you don't think you're old
because you just have this image of
yourself and you go to your 50th college
reunion and all these guys that you used
to know they used to drink bourbon from
the shoe of our daughter in around you
know bloated and bald and and sometimes
even trying to dance to music from the
from our era dark times then you feel
really alter so I don't I'm not I don't
deny in my age but think okay so the the
premise of the book was simple premise
which is that I'm old Lucy's old she's
she's she well I wrote it last year when
I was 17 and she was 10 so 70 70 and and
I was like I think everybody who turned
7 he goes through this phase of like
we don't taking stock and wandering
because you can't keep pretending you
have forever left when you get to be
that age in and I'm looking at Lucia
she's not taking stock she's fine
everything's fine for her she's just
happy as she ever was and I'm thing like
what why can't I do I can't I do that so
the book the book is an attempt to
figure out what I could do to be more
like my dog except we're drinking from
the toilet
what there we listen again that's good I
think triumvirate in an attempt to
figure out how to relate to you as a dog
person I ended up finding a quote that
is from Plato's Republic oh wow as the
dogs are the true philosophers because
they know friend from foe our dogs the
true philosophers know they wait I was
brought because I you don't know Trent
Finn from friend from folks if adolf
hitler were to walk into our house my
god would love him you know as much as
he let her know she's Jewish even though
she's Jewish
she's like so maybe that's you know that
bad it's a philosopher no I wouldn't go
that that far nice nice to people
you know friendly one of your
resolutions from the book is to spend
more time with your your your lawnmower
drill team how did Lucy tell you that
important well the the idea there was
the lawn Rangers they're called the wand
Rangers the world-famous zai Rangers I
want to get them there to Arcola
Illinois and broomcorn capital of the
world okay might as well but and just
because you jealous doesn't mean you
gotta hate them I ask you're not a
member
deeply that way but yeah I mean the idea
there dogs are not self-conscious dogs
whatever they do that they think is fun
they just do it and people let me among
them you get older you think well I'm
too old for that kind of behavior that
sound becoming you know it's not I look
stupid and except for wearing really
skinny jeans I don't think there's
anything old people shouldn't do if they
feel like they want to do them you know
and yet you are anti AARP I'm opposed
well not opposed exactly but they
they have this preposterous attitude
which is you're not getting older
basically it's like you know and and and
this is like all your mail that's not
from AARP is from catheter companies and
yet you know we're supposed to think
that then you know they like they say
let's get rid of all these these memes
about old people can't handle technology
and old people can't do you know you're
never too old for anything and I'm like
really really are when I when I go on a
book tour I you know people often want
to take pictures with their cell phones
which is nice but there is a radical
difference between the way people my age
take the picture and the way young
people take book young people take
picture like this and people my age go
hold it now smile okay no way it's on
Google no wait hold it okay smile no way
it's taking a video no you know that and
then they hand it to a young person so
obviously there there are there's a
reason for their stereotypes about older
people I live in Miami where I see old
people drive all the time and they don't
drive well they just don't so I can't
remember what the question was another
thing is your memory starts to go yeah
but rpr art yeah but art keep saying no
but you know you can do anything like
and I just don't want to get on a plane
with the pilot my age I didn't I want
only young young and alert and able to
take a picture with a cell phone up
there Phoebe and yet old people are
basically driving our politics right
yeah yeah what what's happening there
well NAR it's going to happen to us
seriously I don't know well I started
getting Social Security finally when I
turned 70 years old and I think it's now
the greatest program in the history of
great good excellent
there goes your libertarianism right out
the door let me hear that like now I'm
in the the beating heart of
libertarianism if if you pay into Social
Security your entire life and you know
you're never gonna get any anywhere near
the money
paid in back it's still wrong to take
the money I'm taking the money like
whatever you sow iterance you give I'm
taking the money right and if they came
along and said we've Dave we've
increased Social Security a lot because
old people want it I'd take it probably
I wouldn't say no I can't do that's
wrong I'm a libertarian I think it's
fine to take the money especially if you
paid in I do think the you know the
libertarian moral case here is like you
got a you got a fight against future
people getting the money yeah we you can
really agree on good with that young
libertarians also well if there were
someone not to get all wonky in some way
that younger people could sort by their
way out of it and shift it over in a bit
but then I don't know where I get my
money from exactly because of course you
just tell these young people
you didn't pay into an account knowing
there was no it's a really handy WD in
Iowa it I don't know that's correct yeah
that's a concept that I understand why
the were the problems are with that but
any honest person who's almost dead and
getting money from the government I'm
not gonna change anything so that's the
problem with people like me seems like
we've done good work here today
hammering out your presidential platform
well yeah and let me just add that if I
were the president United States and I
had access to a big chat that could go
anywhere in the world that I wanted it
to anytime I wanted
I'd take that baby all over the world
that's what I would mean I would use I
would use the jet I would be I have a
commitment to jet travel as president
that would be my kind of the cornerstone
yeah it wouldn't be less necessarily
countries that we need to hammer out
agreements would just be nice countries
where we know I wouldn't even try to
hammer anything out when I got there I
just drive around screw up traffic in a
motorcade maybe go to the beach and then
fly home I would never have any meetings
with anybody I would not meet with
foreign leaders about anything they let
so you guys are busy do what you want
I'm just going to the beach you'd be
kind of a Calvin Coolidge of air trouble
yeah just did he do that did you just
here's a pretty chill president yeah
yeah
the very last thing I want to ask you is
in 1994 for some reason your interview
with reason centered heavily around the
strategic helium reserve oh did it it
did I think that dude called
it is still an issue I looked at are we
really people are still mad at people
for filling balloons with our scarce
helium yeah just to have fun
i-i've done that so I just as a closing
question do you still have deep thoughts
about the he'll yeah I would I mean I
guess first of all we need helium
country need you can't have a country
without helium I assume yeah probably
so I would go to war for the helium yeah
you know we got missiles right who has
the helium to be one of the things like
we do
Texas has 30% of the world's helium that
I shoot fire a couple missiles at Texas
if they're not giving it up is that what
the problem is
okay so we're declaring war on Texas
yeah we need to I mean for the Allium
sure I think we've done good we want the
younger generation to have some heal
well we really want them to hear Uncle
Dave inhale helium and then talk with a
funny voice we don't want to give that
up I mean that's America isn't it isn't
that why we have America so that we can
do that and things like it yes thank you
very much Dave Barry for reason TV I'm
Katherine
[Music]
you